Where's Bobby?
I got to let her know the
real killer has to be Crass.
[CRASH]
[GASPS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sorry I'm late.
I hope there aren't
any objections.
Your honor, may I
approach the bench?
I wish you would.
Watch this kid.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) If it pleases the
court-- and I know that I do--
there's something that
I simply must address.
I have heard a report--
and I swear it's not true--
about the secret to
my great success.
So I am here to set
the record straight.
There are just two methods
that I use to help me litigate.
Bells and whistles will get
'em all, although the purest,
they may scoff.
All you need are bells and
whistles to win the case,
though other jurists may
say, you're a disgrace.
The prosecution-- they
may rest, convinced
that they have done their best.
Then I've stopped blowing.
I've stopped clanging.
One more Joe avoids a hanging.
Bells and whistles
are all you need,
plus a comprehensive
knowledge of the law.
[TAPPING]
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Plus a comprehensive
knowledge of the--
thank you to the judge and
all the members of the jury.
I will try to make
this brief, because I
know you're in a hurry.
See, my client-- the defendant--
Dr. Joshua de Skinner--
he was merely at the club
to take his darling
wife to dinner.
He stumbled on the body of
Miss Chelsea-- the decedent.
And you may jump to conclusions.
But the fact is
that you needn't.
The prima facie evidence--
oh, it's an avalanche--
will be expressly
and indubitably
proven circumstantial.
The testimony is hearsay.
And it reeks of retribution.
So what we have here is nothing
but malicious prosecution.
And a verdict of not guilty
is the only just solution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Bells and
whistles are all you need,
plus a comprehensive knowledge--
the kind you get in college--
a comprehensive
knowledge of the law.
I certainly hope this
won't be a split decision.
[CLAPPING]